hello friends I'm Ilana welcome to my
channel today's video
getting demonetized so the point hump
2019 year interview just came out and it
is one of my favorite things I look
forward to it every year fascinating
stuff I've already tweeted a one little
sample this right here just just one
screenshot says that's traffic by game
console people watching porn on
PlayStation the most by 51% also check
out the rise on Vita 23% rise and then
there's this adalah sub-sect
of definitely children who are watching
porn hub on the Nintendo 3ds because
that's the only thing they have access
to very sad I'm never touching another
human's playstation controller ever
again also is it because more people on
Playstations or do people with
Playstations not get laid
so let's come back to that 7th annual
Year in Review basically like it just
tells you a lot of the stats about porn
viewing habits which is pretty
fascinating stuff starting with 42
billion visits to pornhub because all
the data that's transferred votes
messages people send messages that is
definitely a conversation between two
dudes where one of them is pretending to
be a woman most commented words good
love like sexy pretty nice damn maybe
porn just makes people way nicer than
normal I feel like if you looked up the
most commented words on my Instagram
none of those would be there okay this
is where we get into my favorite part of
this tub searches and porn stars the top
search is a super interesting apparently
amateur was the top of the list for 2019
such is which good job
humanity alien also topped the list of
searches did find 2019 a alien insights
ok yeah
what's going on with aliens in poem okay
I guess like poem culture really closely
mimics meme culture such as my area 51
is so drums zero to 160 thousand four
days what do you look at for alien
impregnation alien sex alien hint
alien probe alien belly alien eggs these
alien breeding Zinna wolves that's well
not people are attracted to everything
aliens such demographics women a 33
percent more likely to view alien
related videos compared to men
damn in the 25 to 35 year olds I'm not
having it
ok back to regular insights let's take a
look amateur is number one alien is to
POV is number three that I feel like
that makes sense Mitsuo hmm I had a
boyfriend one time who told me he did
not watch porn which naturally means
you're a liar I should have known he
lied about a lot of stuff but he told me
he didn't watch porn I never believed
that I never believed that that was
always gonna be a lie and then I was
using his laptop to do walk one time and
I guess he had like a browser he used
for pawn and a browser that he used for
work and I went to immediately open the
poem browser not knowing it was the
browser he used for porn and all of his
searches were old men having sex with
young women he was a year older than me
and it gave me a lot of questions that I
never brought up just like what does
that mean for you he went ah what which
part of that is it that a bit that
appeals t it was very confusing for me
fella Delphine probably alongside aliens
is she did really well probably again
because of meme culture oh I didn't
realize this it says Belle Delphine
trolled her beloved followers when she
dedicated a pornhub page to spoof videos
that would be why yeah I think she like
ate a picture of PewDiePie or something
my sexuality was a defendant of time 8x
legends replaced fortnight video games
such as yes ok most search for video
games on pornhub overwatch is number one
I've seen that what fortnight Pokemon no
ok that would be like Ash and Misty
right minecraft is an odd one because
it's blocky but children I I guess that
that's odd to me it's fine
apex legends Resident Evil they're all
pretty hot i Leon's a babe mortal kombat
also all pretty huh Skyrim you can kind
of do whatever you want with that so I
guess that makes sense Borderlands
it's a bit of a strange one which I
completely understand warcraft yeah no I
get it
yeah and some cities mass spect Tomb
Raider Street fight of Final Fantasy
they all make sense to me
except for minecraft we did that Hey
what does that mean the apex legends
peak in February February 18th that roof
killed fortnight when it launched
because I think it came out I mean it
definitely came out in February one date
exactly most social video game
characters Zelda okay is it because
she's like cough it up princess and you
want to see it sexualized I don't hmm
and it's up 138 percent versus 2018 Lara
Croft diva Mario okay boughs it makes
sense Messi makes sense
most of the Pikachu I have questions I
don't know what to make of that it's a
it's a rat what is it
katana ray theory thing sense Jade
Academy bright Bulma
literally all of this makes sense again
except Pikachu
minecraft and Pikachu I'm confused such
as for Resident Evil character Ada Wong
we're up two hundred and eighty eight
percent compared to twenty eighteen that
would be because of Resident Evil 2
remake Pokemon character Pikachu
increased by three hundred and seventy
two percent why I just started out tech
and insights Anita is the most such game
character with such as increasing by one
thousand one hundred and twenty four
percent in 2019 how hard is it Nina okay
yeah she's pretty hot
yeah no I got it I got it
okay 2019 most searched-for terms let's
take a look Japanese hentai one in the
same lesbian always up there milf
oh they have right changings dim Japan's
really jumped up so his Korean so his
Asian okay
stepmom massage anal evany big ass teen
threesome anime public [__] big tits
Chinese gangbang latina caught in Indian
BBC choice flirt
beautiful Lana Rhodes became the most
such fallen star on pornhub let's check
out who that is
Lana Rhodes oh she's super pretty
yeah she's stunning I get it
go you beautiful yeah you get that bread
uh racking up 345 million videos on our
way I don't have much money you make for
that
Lana Rhodes Mia Khalifa Riley Reed I
don't know any of these people well I
mean I know Mia Khalifa and I know who
Kim Kardashian is and that is it male
porn stars I'm not gonna know any of
these names either
I have heard of mandingo before James
Dean I know who that is otherwise number
two didn't even try to get creative with
its name which is Alex Adams Johnny sins
you put effort in Mark Rockwell I feel
like you kind of put effort in Ricky
Johnson mandingo Bruce venture that's a
porn star sounding name if ever I have
heard talk 20 countries by traffic
it's got to be United States number one
followed by Japan okay let's take a look
oh my god the u.s. well maybe that's
because like it's a brand that's known
in the u.s. from also then because
people in the United States watch more
poem than any other countries I wouldn't
buy that United States Japan United
Kingdom Canada France Germany
look at you go Australia tiny population
you're pretty high up proud of you
oh I'm excited about this one time spent
per visit Thailand 11 minutes 20 seconds
nice one Oh United States ain't that bad
ten minutes buddy okay
difference in age 18 to 24 is 60 seconds
less
that makes sense 65 plus being ova also
makes sense female visitors spend an
extra 23 seconds compared to male
visitors only 23 seconds okay know what
you find its work there Australia down
by a second it's been a stressful year
this is the fires a bad I get it you
know you're really overwhelmed I
understand it's gonna come a little
quicker
states that lost the longest in the u.s.
Mississippi nice
Alabama's number two yeah no no Cal
states that lost the shortest okay
Kansas one second decrease for the whole
of the United States
that's Obama I love these ones the
world's most viewed categories lesbian
that's a lotta lies Australia to a lot
of lesbian a Bini that's actually kind
of sweet a lot of these regions make
sense
oh this is got to be interesting okay
women's favorites also lesbian hmm no I
guess that makes sense
popular with women makes I mean a lot of
sense yeah Japanese also women that's
more than men so maybe Japanese is up so
much because women are watching it
threesome evany amateur Anil maturer huh
hand tight milf big dick gangbang women
just get into it
men's favorites under Japanese at the
very top of my back Japanese amateur I
guess I know women i watching amateur to
mature milf hentai have any anal
scissoring wow I would have thought that
that was male designed that's
interesting muscular men makes sense
romantic makes sense all this pretty
much makes sense to me you'd more often
by women compared to men [__] looking
and make sense solo male oh that's sweet
fingering makes sense stats are not as
skewed mail as I would have thought
either like United States 30 70 I mean
I'm a little bit surprised by that but I
feel like biologically men probably just
need to masturbate mole top calories
viewed by women would compared to women
elsewhere in the u.s. Japanese all in
California a bunch of [__] weebs
party okay I'll ask you can get it
alright so obviously this goes a lot
farther you can keep scrolling for a
really long time obviously this is a
tweet that I showed earlier I have
Google searches just all of this stuff
it's it's pretty fascinating TV
characters Holly Quinn avenges is way up
but I'm gonna stop that because I feel
like I 10
just like really enjoy the top of the
list in this video get really long if I
show you all of it so you can check it
out for yourself
of course I mostly really wanted to look
at the video game part I will read the
rest of this though because it is
fascinating stuff alright you guys I
will leave you there I'm Alana I'll see
you guys next time bye